how many men have you ghosted in your
lifetime probably too many to count too
many to count yeah but i might not ghost
you might not ghost me
[Music]
so my name is garrett brown i graduated
college a couple years ago and i'm
currently working on an app to help out
some charities i do value women who can
dress you know not up to standards but
as long as they're comfortable with what
they're wearing and they feel good what
they're wearing that's all i look for
honestly my style right now is uh d
minus tick-tock star
minor
i'll do c minor i'll do c i'll do c plus
how about that we'll do that
okay
all right so we have a wide variety of
some personalities here
i'm liking what i see a lot
you guys are setting me up very well
right now on some blind dates
so number one
what's your name my name is liz liz nice
to meet you nice to meet you i'm garrett
are we wearing this as an everyday shoe
or is this a dress-up shoe yeah this is
an everyday shoe i'd probably wear this
to work or
on a night out with the girls what does
a night out with the girls look like how
crazy we getting ten tequila shots ten
tequilas all right so i'm getting
blocked out by hanging out with her so
that's good to know it's okay i'll take
care of you oh there we go music to my
ears number two
what's your name chloe all right so
those dunks right there
those the left of me those are dungs
these are air force
ones all right so do you consider
yourself to be a fashionable person i'm
more of like a comfortable straight
style type of person okay so you're
active on depop
no no
all right so contestant number three
there's the dunk girl yes
do you have a name i'm jackie so you
must be a depop girl
unfortunately no man
i'm just whiffing right now do i know
anything so what do you consider
yourself your style to be like i'm more
into like the japanese lifestyle called
wabi-sabi and it's like embracing the
imperfect oh that's beautiful i'm
excited to learn a little bit more about
that number four you're hiding your
shoes is that for a good reason or a bad
reason you know what you know what let's
not judge straight off this isn't the
main part of the outfit you know where
are you from and where do you get your
fashion taste from so i'm from toronto
which may explain why i may not have
brought the best shoes i'm very into
fashion just not shoes okay are you a
big drake girl from toronto oh no no no
honey
oh no drake girl i don't know about that
i'm a big aubry fan that's for sure last
we have a nice pair of shoes hiding down
there i'm kaylee do you like to wear
colorful shoes these are actually a gift
i would not have like picked them myself
but i like i like them a lot so you
dress more neutral when it comes to
colors and just clothing in general or i
like neutral shoes because i feel like
colorful shoes don't go with every
outfit so all right well i'm liking what
i'm seeing a lot
man
so number one scares me
one of the 10 tequila shots
she seems like a very wild card but
number one does have the difference you
know a lot of the shoes are similar
toronto is hiding her shoes
[Laughter]
i'm going to
have to let go of toronto
[Music]
oh no
hi you're kidding garrett mickey nice to
meet you all right well i'm very sorry
your outfit is awesome thank you what
are you like six five
you're just short
okay see what happens when you see what
happens they turn on you just like that
right i'll tell everything you want to
hear and they'll turn on here all right
let's go thanks
see you soon see you soon hopefully
my heart's breaking right now but also
we don't know who else is behind there i
can't get too committed to one
i'm liking what i'm seeing
a lot of streetwear oriented okay so
number one man don't you get hot wearing
that i mean we're in california i don't
know how you can that's how you you know
keep your body looking good you just
sweat throughout the day
so when you say you'll take care of me
what is that what does that mean you
know i'll turn you on your side so you
won't throw up after the night of
drinking you know give you some soup
some soup and you'll turn me on my side
so i can throw up on the floor instead
of the bed well i'll put the trash can
there so i don't have to clean it up you
can take it out oh so i'll take it out
in the morning okay that's perfect yeah
in the morning okay yeah
moving on to number two
be honest with me when i ask you this
question okay how many men have you
ghosted in your lifetime
probably too many to count
too many to count yeah but i might not
go see you might not ghost me you seem
like a nice man so far all right well
i'll take that i like the whole charity
thing oh you're hyping me up too much
now all right
what does your relationship with your
dad look like my dad yeah i'm a big
daddy's girl he's like my best friend
big daddy's girl yeah number three i
wasn't expecting those pants they look
very good i like them they sit well what
kind of pants are those they're corduroy
it it's actually overalls okay so it's
one piece up top yes why do you think
you're single right now just truly just
have not met the one the one okay so
you're looking for the one the one right
now i mean as you get older you have no
choice
number four so tell me a little about
yourself what do you want people to
think when they see your outfit i always
say like i dress like elevated casual
like i want to look put together but i
want to look comfortable and like i
could fit in in like any scene and then
where'd you say you were from i'm from
kansas city now do people in kansas city
normally dress like this like when i go
home now i definitely get some like
looks my way kind of some disapproving
ones sometimes
based on what i know
unfortunately
number one scares me a little bit the
drinking the she knows i'm going to be
throwing up so we're drinking a lot and
i'm trying to get past that you know i'm
trying to
do well for myself
[Music]
oh hey hello
i'm liz nice to meet you garrett nice to
meet you i'm sorry we can't go out
clubbing it's okay you know i'm a very
beautiful woman thank you you're very
beautiful
thank you and i'm taking another l today
here ladies and gentlemen
bye bye bye
[Music]
all right there we go
see now i'm starting to picture
more what they look like i get an actual
understanding of their personality a
little more so number one now what are
your
red flags and men so i can make sure
that i do not fall into those you have
to be funny i'm really sarcastic and i
feel like people take it as mean
sometimes so you have to get my humor
will you make me cry on a date probably
i love toxic women that's that's my
thing right there so number two the
overalls i love them yeah thank you i
think it looks great i love the brown if
you could pick
one thing about your dream guy that
matters the most to you what would it be
and why literally just like being
open-minded and open to trying new
things what kind of things you think you
could introduce me to new food new music
i'm really into
indian food at the moment and like
mediterranean and ethiopian food oh
right huh last one
i'm loving the blazer thank you it
screams yeah i'm here to make some money
i'm here to do my thing get out of my
way or i'll spit on you and i love that
yeah sure
so what is our first date looking like
we could pick up some thai takeout and
then go somewhere really pretty and have
like a sunset picnic by the ocean we
could play a game like card game or
something just like a really chill but
like plenty of quality time i'm
absolutely with that so do you consider
yourself a big nature and like beach
kind of girl i would consider myself
more mountains if i went on a hike with
you and i fell then i hurt my ankle
would you be able to carry me to safety
oh yeah firemen carry over the shoulder
fireman carry all right so we got a
stronger right there i'm with that
[Music]
i thought i had some oh
no
it's just so hard cause i like all of
them they all have great outfits and
i've been oh for two so far so that just
makes me feel even better knowing that
i'm gonna mess it up again so
unfortunately number two the middle one
will be the first one that i'll be
letting go today
i can't look again i can't do it again i
can't do it
oh hey yup another elf are you kidding
me
garrett jackie nice to meet you i'm so
sorry for letting you go you look
absolutely great hopefully in the future
you're good you can put me on some more
of that food and some music all right
thank you
oh
the last person i will be letting go is
drum roll please do you have any drums
in here
[Music]
unfortunately number one i will be
letting number one walk today
come on are you kidding me
i'm so sorry it's okay i love the bucket
hat you were hiding that under there
come on now it was nice meeting you yeah
good luck in the future thanks and stop
being so toxic right i'll try
i'm sweating doing this man this is
heartbreaking i don't want to do this
[Music]
hey garrett kaley nice to meet you nice
to meet you too
it's finally nice to see you yes you do
as well i love the outfit it looks great
i love the change you're like how i like
to describe myself like elevated casual
like you got the ysl and you got some
clean shoes but you're still like super
comfy looking and like i know you're
comfortable in what you're wearing you
know absolutely all right perfect see
that's the vibe i was trying to give off
she read it perfectly
we're thinking like each other already
so oh there will be some ig swap today
that's for sure yeah i don't give my
number until the second date it goes
what i don't want a bunch of random
dudes to have my number
a bunch of random dudes how many dates
are you going on not that many but you
know what i mean if i go on like one
date i don't want this dude down my
number forever okay i mean i don't know
i think i caught her slipping i guess
we'll see i like her a lot she's got a
nice sense of style she's cute
she means business a lot of people want
her number i got a lot of competition i
don't know we'll see what happens in the
future
[Music]
do i have to yeah
the devil himself
the devil himself that's great can we
rate your outfit yes give it give it
sweet
giving mommy issues